oui bonjour Ingrid bonjour à tous
rebelote participation au 2e tour
presque compi conforme que qu'au premier
tour dimanche dernier alors si on prend
le détail de cette participation
département par département on se
souvient d'abord que c'est en Côte d'Or
qu'on avait le moins voté au premier
tour à midi ça n'est pas mieux
aujourd'hui 19,2 % contre 19,3 dimanche
dernier dans la Nièvre la participation
à la mi journée était de 20,4 % dimanche
dernier moins 1 point aujourd'hui 19,1 %
c'est en sonéloire et dans Lyonne que la
participation était la plus élevée au
premier tour aujourd'hui à midi la
sonéloire a voté à 24,27 %, à peu de
chose près la même chose qu'au premier
tour
24,47 24 29 % de participation dans
Lyonne meilleur taux à la mi-journée en
Bourgogne un peu plus qu'au premier tour
23,93 %. voilà pour ces premier chiffres
à la mi-journée à ce soir